why is an American woman talking like
she's Australian on The Bachelor FEMA
has Colton about that and why he goes
AWOL this season how long were you off
the grid I was gone for a while I in
that moment and the feelings that I was
feeling I left the show and I just
needed time to myself
so for a moment The Bachelor quit The
Bachelor there was no Bachelor Colton
says that was his rock bottom during
production the shocking footage was
teased at the end of the show last night
but where exactly did the bachelor go
but Colton what do you do because you
don't have a cellphone you seem to be in
the woods what you do when you're a
little bonfire fight off some coyotes or
whatever we got to do did you cry when
you're off the grid oh of course of
course
et spoke exclusively with Bachelor host
Chris Harrison this morning via Skype
and he says Colton's virginity may have
been a bigger prize and a proposal early
on the game was raised a little bit
because of that if the women I think
definitely saw trophy their game on game
definitely on and remember this moment
sir nice to meet you nice to meet you we
got a nice accent where're you from
um Australian here's what you didn't see
the 24 year old model from LA eventually
fest up to her fake accent could you
tell it all that it was fake did you
have an inkling I didn't really know it
was a good or bad accent she did
eventually reveal to you that night she
did yeah okay were you shot um you know
I don't know if I was shocked I was sort
of relieved hello so she's like I was
like oh thank god alright let's just
talk do you end up with someone cold
I'm not gonna spoil the show I want
people to have fun and I think people
think might think they have an idea of
which way it's going on you don't have a
clue I've been around this guy at events
and the ladies love Colton so this
season will be very very interesting
[Music]